what's going on reject nation Greg Alva
here John we are gonna continue Cobra
Kai together right now the first two
were free on YouTube so to watch the
rest gotta go on YouTube read those two
I had to cut down to ten minutes for the
reaction part because they were getting
blocked full-length TV show reactions
are all over on our patreon we cover a
lot of shows on our patreon actually oh
yeah see most of our TV show reactions
even the 10-minute cuts have been
blocked on you - I don't know how some
channels get away with it honestly but
we are covering a lot of shows over
there
full length right now we were almost
done with the first season of my hero
academia one more episode left of black
lightning a few episodes left the season
2 of Jessica Jones I am almost done with
attack on Titan season 1 almost done
with the flash season 4 Full Metal
Alchemist Brotherhood over here with
John Riverdale he finished season 1 is
on season 2 right now Atlanta season 2
Gotham I have started doing it per
requests full-length TV show reactions
over there all only on season 1 and now
we have Cobra Kai on the list Hey oh
yeah here we go full like TV show
reactions over there I know promoting a
lot of that there and I just got back
from the gym so I'm like I feel really
hot and sweaty right now
that's perfect you're like in character
women that's why the AC is on anyway
let's hop to it
[Music]
Oh Miguel he's got a really train she
thinks he's mastered Halloween dance in
the first Karate Kid or some Boyden
cliches hey hey
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
ouch that's especially mean down I also
feel sorry for like the actress who has
to be on the receiving end of that that
is so close to where we live you want to
come visit come on man get on Yelp
passing out flyers a hard man
no one likes flyers anymore get on Yelp
the show makes everyone know they look
like jerks yeah everybody who's not a
protagonist oh don't even think it do it
wax off do it wax off man I mean Miguel
was waxing off earlier ha ha ha ha I
want to have some alone time yeah
training's can see why so many asses to
kick
click on the snake look at them you're
happy parenting I loved it
that is a setup that is a setup drowning
is looks like such an easy board to
break he has no leg muscles yet
nice nice nice bad at all
his hairdos even getting money yeah you
knew it but you could defend yourself
past yeah it's the Casa no it was
wearing over they all worry that all the
Cobra Cobra Kaiser where that that's
that's what it was yeah I want to make
sure my daughter don't get the bag a big
gift
Johnny why don't you understand how the
internet works so embarrassing she's my
favorite I care the most about her class
thanks very knowledge again PTSD
son that seemed even more painful in
that quick flash about this building
[Laughter]
yeah cuz giant Lawrence is like a good
guy but when he interacts he seems like
a bad shoot he's gonna walk right in and
this predictable scenario it's still
creepy
why to what end
she couldn't go like glow on your ass
right now people so like a telescope
like that mean if they feel would stand
up for their faces Savior this is such a
unique show I'm so surprised at how good
it is Oh what if she came back that
would be full oh this is getting
personal I gotta kick some more kids
asses
[Music]
yeah I don't wanna watch I wanna watch
this from cutting cut in the next on I
mean I don't have talked plenty about
this show on the first two reactions but
this show continues to impress me of its
ability to go in and out like seamlessly
through natural comedy some stuff a
little bit wacky but just the right
level then gets like dramatic and an
intense i it's shocking how good they
actually weave through all these
different elements of the show yeah this
is first few episodes feel like the
perfect blend of off shooting from the
tone of the original movie borrowing
some of those aesthetics but also
updating it to the intense abilities of
now like I feel like they pitched this
really really nicely there's elements in
this episode that were a little bit
predictable and cliche then I'm
wondering like is that fine though for
the show
because that's like 80s nostalgia but it
also seems like more than an 80s and
install just show so I kind of feel like
this show should be a little bit better
than that
there I love this episode it's just like
certain moments like when they go to the
pool access to this yeah or or you know
that it's not gonna be his dick yeah
gonna mess up walking on this you know
all this is coming and you know the kids
gonna throw down but Miguel's probably
still gonna get his ass yeah yeah
they're not quite ready yet they're but
it's all in the details at the moment
sigh the bullying though is so extreme
but necessary for the motivation of
coporate I that's the cool flip about it
it's kind of a head scratchers I know
bullying is a very real thing but for a
show that tries to be as authentic to
what Los Angeles the valley area is like
I remember being this way and I feel
like oh it's not like this especially
it's like the bullying is so extreme
here I would be curious yeah because I
mean you know you hear about bullying
and cyber bullying in schools and stuff
like that still oh yes day and yeah it's
like I don't know if everyone around is
as much of a dick as it appears they are
in this year oh yeah but I guess that's
one of those things that I do kind of
wish was more nuanced but at the same
time coming
of the original Karate Kid I get it oh
yeah that's one of those tone well
that's what I mean is like there's tonal
parts that I question and predictability
parts that question but then I'm like
this also comes out of the Karate Kid so
maybe this is all just very intentional
on what they're yeah it's like there's a
certain allowance I feel like you have
of familiar things and yeah no
heightened elements it really hit me in
the moment where Johnny and Danny
encounter each other by the locker room
how brilliant the dynamic is between
them and the writing of this show too
because Todd because Danny is just our
dad who's like why is it it's trying to
be a good parent though and a good up
he's just trying to do like the morally
right thing but he's making mistakes
whereas Johnny thinks well but he's
overbearing johnny is like questionable
but he's a good dude you know like he's
just a little bit on the dirty rugged
side and Johnny's the character I'm
easily more drawn to like I love seeing
Danny Larusso again I love the Ralph
Macchio's updated performance of him and
take on him but easily this show it's
called Cobra Kai and easily Johnny
Lawrence is the one I'm most gravitated
towards and to follow him as a
protagonist now instead of a now yeah it
forces part of the hook of the show like
seeing the first episode that's part of
what hooked me is like oh we're gonna
focus on this guy well the first episode
is very Johnny Lawrence Bass the second
one's more based this one seemed to have
a good back-and-forth between cutting
between them yeah really fluid and so
when they encountered each other in the
locker room I thought that was great
because there's just a switch like
between who these people really are like
when you see them on their own time but
then when you bring them together that
kind of like evil sinister stare that
just goes off in Johnny Lawrence's eyes
like that bully in him just comes back I
feel like there's a fascinating thing to
that dynamic specifically because when
you focus on them each individually you
kind of root for them both you see
what's good about them you want them to
succeed and then when they get together
you immediately see them at odds and
what they project onto each other what I
really liked about this show too is what
we all wanted they're giving us in great
fashion Daniel Larusso Johnny Lawrence
but then they have these other
characters in here teenagers who I
thought I wouldn't give two shits about
honestly who I really like the miguel's
storyline
great and is the heart of what made the
Karate Kid the Karate Kid and then even
the stuff with his daughter and this
like side stuff that doesn't really seem
linked to Cobra Kai maybe the girl who
keeps getting bullied will become a part
of Cobra Kai that could be an element
that I think would be neat and
interesting all of that is like do the
subject just makes your heart well
that's even interesting in and of itself
because you've got Johnny paired off
with the arguably Danny Larusso type in
Miguel and then you've got larusso's
family like his daughter is more
teetering on the Cobra Kai edge of the
spectrum she's in with the family crowd
of girls and whatnot and yet it's
building to the point where Cobra Kai is
the one we're gonna help out the kids
who are bullied like a bunch of little
irrespective of this show I think
tonally they've managed to find a really
unique tone that I wasn't expecting this
show to do let's give it like any time
the show starts just two minutes in yeah
I think they're really smart in choosing
to it's like the same thing that works
for me about Evil Dead whenever they
check back in is like time has clearly
passed and we're dealing with these
characters under different circumstances
at a different point in their life we're
not just returning to be like oh let's
revitalize some trite beef and have a
Redux of Karate Kid like it's expansive
but also has the core in task room
that's what they ought to do you know
alright guys well Cobra Kai full-length
TV show reactions all over our patreon
you can check us out over there weekly
Q&A is music video coverage as well and
you can subscribe to the reject nation
click that notification bell not sure if
this video will remain up on YouTube
kapow YouTube is and you on the
flippety-flip and comment below what
costume you're wearing to the Halloween
dance